usually average people don't care about
or even know who the federal reserve
chair is but ever since the pandemic hit
and jerome turned on the money printer
he's become one of the biggest memes on
the internet from making the money
printer go bird to his promise of
inflation is just transitory jerome has
truly become a legend within the retail
space
savers with a lot of cash despise his
policies as they watch their savings
evaporate away but investors have had a
blast buying the dip and going to the
moon well at least till recently
in the last few fed meetings jerome has
become a bit more hawkish and he's made
it clear that interest rates are going
up soon and this has resulted in one of
the worst januaries ever in stock market
history but i don't think you can really
blame him when you consider that he's
already pumped up the money supply by 6
billion wait never mind 6 trillion
dollars within just the last 2 years
so jerome has no doubt made his mark in
economic history but who even is jerome
powell and how did he become the money
printer
taking a look back jerome hayden powell
was born on february 4th 1953 in
washington dc
he was one of six children to patricia
and jerome powell and yes his father's
name was also jerome his family wasn't a
billionaire rich or anything but they
did hold pretty prestigious positions
within society for example his father
was a private lawyer and given that they
lived in washington dc he likely served
some pretty notable figures similarly
jerome's maternal grandfather was the
dean of the columbus school of law and a
lecturer at georgetown law school
considering jerome's background i don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
jerome was sent to an elite private
school called georgetown preparatory
school
currently for day students yearly
tuition comes in at 38 330
and for boarding students tuition comes
in at 62 000 90
this makes it the fourth most expensive
boarding school in the us
anyway moving on in jerome's elite
journey for his bachelor's jerome
attended princeton university and
majored in politics
after graduation jerome became a
legislative assistant to a pennsylvania
senator named richard schweiker he only
did this for a year though before he
went back to school this time he
attended georgetown university and
pursued a law degree
while at georgetown jerome served as the
editor-in-chief at the georgetown law
journal so it looks like he had an
interest in journalism but he never
explored this interest much further
after graduating in 1979 he hopped
around from one job to another as he
tried to find his calling first jerome
moved to new york city and started
clerking for a judge in the u.s court of
appeals he did this for two years before
he switched over to a law firm called
davis poke and wardwell he worked here
for another two years before finally
switching over to werble and mcmillan he
didn't stick around for long here either
as he left just one year later in 1994
but this was his last job as a
traditional lawyer ever since then papa
powell has been all about the moolah
in 1984 jerome picked up a job at an
investment bank called the dillon read
and co initially he focused on the legal
side of financing merchant banking and
the merger slash acquisitions but with
the time he was able to climb the
corporate ladder and become vice
president he worked here for a total of
six years before he jumped over to the
u.s treasury in 1990. jerome wasn't the
first one to make this jump in 1988 the
chairman of dylan reed and go nicolas of
brady left his position after being
appointed as the u.s secretary of the
treasury by president ronald reagan i'm
not sure if nicholas put in a good word
for jerome but in 1992 jerome was
appointed as the undersecretary of the
treasury for domestic finance by
president george h.w bush this was
perfect timing for jerome as this put
him in charge of overseeing a treasury
bond scandal if you weren't aware
there's a limit to buying treasury bonds
during initial offerings any individual
person or entity can only buy a maximum
of 5 million worth of treasury bonds
during each offering a trader at solomon
brothers named paul moser however was
submitting false bids in an effort to
bypass the bond limit but he of course
got caught and jerome was in charge of
overseeing the investigation and
sanctioning solomon brothers solomon
ended up being fined 190 million dollars
and they were forced to set aside 100
million dollars as a restitution fund
the ceo john gottfriend was also
borrowed from serving as the ceo of any
other brokerage firm just as this case
wrapped up though so did jerome's time
at the treasury in 1993 president bill
clinton took office and he brought with
him a new slew of secretaries so jerome
returned to the private industry and
picked up a job as a managing director
at bankers trust but unfortunately the
trust would get stuck up in some legal
trouble right after jerome joined you
see banker's trust had convinced some
big corporate clients including png that
they should invest some of their money
in riskier investments such as
derivatives these clients agreed and the
banker's trust went ahead and made these
investments but as you might have
guessed this led to substantial losses
and the clients ended up suing banker's
trust for misrepresenting the risk
involved and they would win clearly this
was not somewhere that jerome wanted to
be around for long so in 1995 he packed
his bags and returned to dillon read and
go but this time jerome also had a bunch
of side hustles going on as well
for example in 1997 he became a partner
at the carlow group and founded the
industrial group he worked there till
2005 at which point he co-founded a
private investment firm called several
capital partners the firm was focused on
leveraging opportunity investments
within the industrial sector and finally
in 2008 jerome became a managing partner
at the global environmental fund as the
name suggests the firm was focused on
making sustainable energy investments
all these side hustles and jobs kept
jerome busy for nearly 20 years but
eventually he circled back to politics
starting in 2010 jerome served as a
visiting scholar at the bipartisan
policy center and this was once again a
perfect timing for jerome as the debt
ceiling crisis rolled around in 2011.
if you follow politics you'll know that
every few years congress has to raise
the debt ceiling if they don't the
government will run out of money and
default on their loans usually it's a
given that congress will raise the debt
ceiling but politicians often like to
use it as a bargaining chip for example
the democrats might say that they'll
help the republicans raise a debt
ceiling as soon as the republicans help
them approve another round of stimulus
checks or raise the minimum wage
generally one side gives in close to the
deadline and things work out but every
so often neither side gives in and we
enter the risk of default and one of
these situations unfolded in 2011. as a
visiting scholar jerome became one of
the leading voices advocating for
bipartisan support and raising the debt
ceiling he presented all the negative
implications of not raising the debt
ceiling such as ruined credit and an
irreparable reputation it's not like the
other politicians weren't aware of these
implications but the bipartisan policy
center ramped up the pressure to the max
congress did eventually raise the debt
ceiling but it wasn't before being
downgraded from aaa to double a plus by
the snp in the meantime president obama
was having a hard time filling a seat at
the federal reserve he had initially
nominated a democrat named jeremy c
stein but senate republicans refused to
prove his nomination obama had to
nominate someone that republicans would
accept and who better to nominate than
the bipartisan man who was advocating
for the debt ceiling to be raised and
with that obama nominated jerome powell
to the federal reserve board of
governors and he took office on may 25
2012. two years later obama renominated
him for a 14-year term and the senate
approved this so jerome isn't going
anywhere till at least 2028 now this
doesn't mean that he'll remain chairman
but he will at least be a board member
anyway ever since jerome took off his
he's actually mostly been a hawk in
other words he's mostly supported
tightening of monetary policy in
september of 2012 for instance he was a
massive skeptic of a third round of
quantitative easing similarly one of his
biggest goals has been ending banks that
are quote unquote too big to fail in
2017 he described the current state of
fannie mae and freddie mac the two
biggest mortgage providers as quote
unacceptable and unsustainable he
further elaborated that the next couple
of years may be our last chance to end
their monopoly and prevent past mistakes
from being repeated and jerome soon got
the perfect opportunity to take action
as president trump nominated him for
chair of the federal reserve in november
of 2017.
as soon as jerome became chairman he
continued to raise interest rates and
announced his plans to reduce the fed's
balance sheet he wanted to reduce their
holdings from 4.5 trillion dollars to
2.5 to 3 trillion dollars at first
investors didn't care too much but as
the effects of his tightening started to
take hold they became more and more
irritated in the last quarter of 2018
indices like the s p 500 and the nasdaq
corrected a full 20 percent and trump
was not happy by any means one of
trump's signature bragging points was
how good the stock market was doing but
with jerome tightening the stock market
was no longer doing that well
so trump started to publicly criticize
jerome for doing a terrible job and
started discussing the possibility of
firing jerome with all this mounting
pressure jerome backed off on the
quantitative tightening but he made it
clear that he was not going to return to
quantitative easing he was just giving
the market a chance to breathe and he
would return to quantitative tightening
when appropriate you could say that this
aged like milk though as kobet came
around just a couple of months later and
papa powell turned on the money printer
and hasn't stopped since this has led to
exponential runs in growth stocks
cryptocurrencies real estate and
basically everything you can think of
from the very beginning a lot of critics
argue that the success of money printing
would lead to excessive inflation jerome
acknowledges concerns by arguing that
this inflation would be transitory but
this is honestly super misleading when
people hear that inflation will be
transitory they're left to believe their
price hikes are temporary and their
prices will go down but this is not what
transducer inflation means transitory
inflation simply means that the
inflation rate will go back down to
average numbers for example let's say an
iphone costs one thousand dollars if we
see super bad inflation of 10 to 1 year
the price of the iphone will rise to
1100
even if inflation drops to 2 the next
year and the inflation was transitory
the price of the iphone would still rise
to eleven hundred and twenty two dollars
for prices to return we would need nine
percent deflation and jerome has by no
means promised that so the truth is a
lot of the price hikes we've seen are
here to stay but recently jerome has
changed his tone when it comes to
inflation probably because of joe biden
all this rampant inflation is making
biden look bad and midterm elections are
coming up at the same time jerome needed
biden to be nominated him so it's likely
that jerome has become more hawkish to
please biden in the most recent fomc
meeting jerome announced that they will
complete the taper by early march and
that rate hikes and quantitative
tightening are coming soon after so it
looks like the glorious or not so
glorious days of the money printer are
finally coming to an end but there's no
doubt that jerome will forever be known
as the legendary money printer of the
coveted pandemic did jerome's money
printer help you or hurt you comment
that down below
also drop a like if you wish you could
print money just like papa powell and of
course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one